Der Weststrand: über 40 Kilometer weißer,
feiner Sandstrand.
Hier ist das Meer wild;
nirgendwo sonst an deutschen Küsten
krachen die Wellen mit solcher Wucht
auf Land.
Genau deshalb lieben Windsurfer
dieses Revier.
Und die Luft ist besonders gesund.
Die Brandung versprüht feinste Tröpfchen
voller Meeresmineralien.
Der Wind bläst den Alltag einfach weg.
Quer über die Dünen führen euch
Wander- und Radwege
an die Ostseite der Insel.
Es ist die sanftere.
Hier erstreckt sich das Wattenmeer.
Die Gezeiten bestimmen das Leben:
Alle sechs Stunden geht oder kommt
das Meer.
Als besonders schützenswerte
Naturlandschaft gehört das Wattenmeer
seit 2009 zum UNESCO-Welterbe –
mitsamt seinen Bewohnern.
Friesisches Ambiente findet ihr in den
zehn Inseldörfern.
Der Ort Kampen steht für Luxus.
Mit seinen Edelboutiquen ist er Laufsteg
der Schönen und Reichen –
zu jeder Jahreszeit.
Sylt ist die mondänste der deutschen
Nordseeinseln.
Ganz traditionell: das Friesendorf Keitum.
Die meisten Häuser stammen aus dem
18. Jahrhundert und sind Kapitänshäuser.
Im Heimatmuseum erfahrt ihr, wie die
Menschen früher auf Sylt gelebt haben.
Sie waren Seefahrer und Walfänger,
Kapitäne und Fischer –
bis so gegen Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts
der Tourismus kam
und aus der Fischerinsel
eine Urlaubsinsel wurde.
Ich finde: Auf Sylt kann jeder sein ganz
persönliches Highlight finden –
irgendwo zwischen Meer und Watt, Luxus
und friesischer Gemütlichkeit.